well good evening or good morning or
good afternoon whatever's appropriate to
see you in your time zone
uh my name is nigel brown and i'll be
going to talk about the designer
benzodiazepines and pregabalin
and they seem to be coming a lethal
combination together
so what i thought i'd do is run first
start with some statistics to give you
an idea of the problem
that we've got in the northeast of
england then some of the benzodiazepine
types that we're finding
and then moving on into the
benzodiazepine receptor and how that's
is important for the the effects of
these drugs have and then changing
tracts slightly
into pagabolin and then d gabapentin
principle interaction with opiates but
that
is this also affecting the
benzodiazepines as well
then at the end some methodological
issues and this is particularly for a
local hospital
whilst yes we are a toxicology lab we're
attached to a district general hospital
rather than a central teaching hospital
with a university backup and that brings
about
particular problems but also some
advantages
so here's the statistics these are the
drugs found at post mortem
this past year and as you can see
paracetamol is the most common drug
probably because it's
wisely spread to you widespread use but
also it's only unlocks the drug
substances next most common of the
opioids and the opiates that's your
morphines
heroines tramadols and the like an
antidepressant
this is all the drugs we found at
post-mortem so it's not just drug users
deaths
it's just anything that we get in my
database isn't good enough to be able to
pick out the
drug users and as you can see the next
most common class are progabaline and
gabapentin and we pretty well
exclusively see those in drug related
deaths
then below pregabalin and gabapentin
there's cocaine
then diet of pound which is the most
popular benzodiazepines
and so on down the line i've included
sopper clove
because that's a diet of pain
benzodiazepine like drug
but and is very popular particularly in
one part of the region
and then moving down i'll come to why
promethazine is highlighted
in a little while and the only other
thing that i want to point out is
ecstasy
um the suggestions particularly from
intelligence
um that there's a large amount of
ecstasy in the region
but we don't see much bit of post-mortem
at all
and also we don't see much of it in
we're screening the audience we drug
recovery services
the clinicians in the area are getting
quite concerned as a ticking time bomb
of ecstasy users who are slowly
developing comorbidities
and in five ten years time they're going
to be
banging on the door the recovery
services with long-term issues
due to the continued use so
this slide gives you an idea of the
benzodiazepine types we've been picking
up
if you look at the top graph that nice
sort of crimsony red color is it dyes a
pan
so pretty constant throughout but if you
look
at around about the third quarter of
2018 we suddenly start
getting an increased number of the
benzodiazepines
okay um and yes we have our cutoff was
installed in the
fourth quarter of 2017 so it might be
related to that
but having talked to public health in
the t
side area which has got that nice blue
circle in it which is where the
benzodiazepine problem is
is concentrated um that's so intelligent
as well they started hitting the streets
in the second half of 2018. we're based
up in northumberland
which is north newcastle where the red
arrow where it's red circle is
and we don't see nearly so many of these
benzodiazepines it seems to be a
site problem the bottom graph
shows you the illicit benzodiazepines
that are appearing
alphazolam or depending how you
pronounce it was the first one really to
appear in big numbers
that's died away now and alphazolam
flubromazoleum have taken over the
tizoram
seems to be there quite a lot and i'll
come to that one again in a few minutes
with a nice couple of pictures
we've also added in um promethazine and
i'll say white about
in a few minutes in the next slide or
two
so this is why we've got promethazine in
there
we were sent to xanax tablet to analyze
by public health
and didn't contain any benzodiazepine at
all
it contains some amantadine
cyproheptadine and promethazine
a rather strange combination but it ties
in reports
from the european monitoring center for
drugs and drug addiction
that this was also being found in cases
from spain and indeed switzerland
so it's clearly there is a reason why
people are
using this combination
so additional factors we found to be
very useful
in our if you like finding these drugs
we've got very good communication with
one of the public health departments in
the region
we also take part in the regional drugs
related deaths group
where we are able to swap intelligence
and information with the police
recovery services clinicians public
health
and so on it keeps us up to date with
new drugs that appearing in the scene
and really without this would be so much
less successful
we also offer a clinical service we're
primarily a clinical laboratory not a
forensic one
so what we find in the dead informs what
what we should be looking for in a
living and vice versa
because yes it's interesting to find
these drugs but really what we want to
do is to use the information
to inform the clinical services what's
happening so they can get the warnings
out to the users that there's a strong
batch of whatever
out there
so moving on to the benzodiazepine
structures
i've taken this picture from a very good
book ended by hans maurer
and simon brandt and i really do
recommend it it goes through all the
different classes of
the novel psychoactives here's your
typical
benzodiazepine structure just above and
this
is basically diazepam but you can see
you can add groups or
here the on the molecule which will
affect its activity quite widely
towards the top of the screen there
you've got the structure of
a triozo derivative benzodiazepine so
like alphazolam
and again higher these tend to have
higher activities
and again you can modify the activities
for all these different groups
so as you can see from the basic
structure you've got a large number of
different molecules that you can make
so even more annoying is that these
benzodiazepines have been synthesized
using information on the patent
applications or in the literature
so for example you've got this paper
telling you how to make the make the
things
annoyingly you don't even have to pay
for the pdf when you click on the link
it's open access so anybody can get to
it
some drugs like frazer pam or tislam are
prescribed drugs in other countries um
we've also seen drugs purporting to be
to mazapan some fairly good
fakes both and diazepam
but these actually contain the more
potent benzodiazepines we aren't
we haven't tried to work a how much
droplets per sample per tablet
so it may be that the strength isn't
that much stronger
but some of these newer bent starter
pins have some quite nasty
potent effects that you wouldn't get
from the
tamazapan tablet of the same strength
this slide attempts to give you an idea
of the strength of different
benzodiazepines
typically you work out your strength
either by
a rodent model sailor a poor pressure
test
or a tail flip test or you're doing it
within sept receptor binding and tissue
culture
very difficult to translate other times
into what the effect would be on your
average human being
now picking up geyser pam we can all do
it nice and easily
there's metabolites crms certified rest
materials
for the metabolites they're widely
available and it's easy to tune up the
tandem mass spectrometer
opersolum um a fair bit stronger
twenty percent of the doses in the urine
as a parent drug so again you can pick
that up nice and easily
a tissue lamb you've got a
metabolite alpha hydroxy template we've
got a tumor or
possibly actually twice was long
half-life um
and really we've noticed that we only
really picked this up in urine
using the tandems with a hydroxy
metabolite the parent drug isn't really
in the organ well
metabolism is probably gluconidation and
hydroxylation but the
trouble is because this drug isn't is
quite new there isn't that much
information out there
as to what the metabolism is across the
population yes you can do a study in one
or two
say fatalities or patients you know
taking the drug or you can get some
get data from tissue culture but you
can't get that broad
data you would get from a large
population to get an idea of what the
best metabolite is to target detection
for that drug
there's also only a certified reference
material currently available for the
parent drug
glubromazoleum similar position
i've included through azerpam because we
had two cases involving this drug
several years ago now this is quite a an
issue with this drug
very long half-life t-max is about seven
hours
and it takes a couple of hours for the
effects to kick in the danger
is with this long lag time is that the
person taking the drug thinks
that she's not very good drugs they'll
have another tablet and then it
kicks in and then its course is too late
and i've included software clone
because it's so widely used binds the
same receptor
and this is easy to pick up the
metabolites crms are available
and it's it's easy to pick up
something else that you need to consider
when you get in these drugs is the
effects they have
so this is of my paper by group and
scandinavia
where they were looking at the user's
responses to using food blood and zola
okay now you can see why user would want
heavy hypnotic
sedative effects but there's issues
about tolerance
tolerance develops rapidly and the
withdrawal is actually often quite
severe and long-lasting
some are reporting euphoria and tests
well b and c folk might want that
but there's been serious incidents where
people users have been admitted to
hospital
needing acute psychiatric treatment or
taken or arrested
um so these drugs aren't
nice and safe and very often that the
drug companies start developing
they've seen the side effects and
they've stopped work on them
and this gives you an idea of it islam
which is probably the
most common of the illicit benzos that
we're seeing at the moment this comes
from the local press
and they they um the police busted
basically a factory where they're
producing pills in industrial quantities
they've got a cement mixer
okay for mixing the stuff together and
vast numbers of a tislam tablets being
churned out there
for sale local local area and this
actually
was in the sunderland area i think which
is halfway between
um t-side and ourselves up in in
northumberland
okay so to summarize benzodiazepines
large number of possible molecules the
detection patterns are constantly
changing and available across our patch
so we can't apply what we find down on t
side to what to look for
up in northumberland or in newcastle
upon time
the metabolism of the newer drugs is
unknown so it's not clear what to look
for in the clinical urine samples
and of course for clinical work if
they're being tested in the clinic using
one of the instant pots that's the
the treatment of the pots they use in
the clinic
will these actually pick up the newer
types so with the newer
the new benzodiazepines are they
actually being used to get around the
drug testing
so benzodiazepines themselves these bind
to the gaba
a receptor and gaba gamma benefit acid
is the main inhibitory neurotransmitter
in the cns it's a very big receptor
and this is a picture of taken from from
the reference there you can see
and what happens is gaba binds if the
channel opens
chloride ions go into the cell and it
makes it less likely to fire an impulse
this receptor is quite a complex one
you've got site to bind benzodiazepines
probably ethanol um
steroids neurosteroids and so on as you
can see from the picture
so it's a very complex receptor
adding to its complexity is because then
the receptor is actually acting in two
different ways you've got the
traditional
sort of receptor on the postsynaptic
membrane so responding to release of
transmitter from the
nerve cell downstream but you've also
got the same receptor in the membrane
away from the synapse and these
seem to confirm a longer term inhibition
um
it's a mistake to think of nerve
transmission as just simple on
off it's actually much more subtle than
that and there's lots of
modulation and variation depending on
your
receptor receptor types where it is what
other factors you are interacting
the gaba receptor itself it's got five
silver units formed around the central
paw
and if you look at that little list
there there's a huge range of different
variants that are known
okay so there's no such thing as a
a gaba a receptor that will do exactly
the same no matter where it is in the
brain
typically the major form of the brain is
alpha 1 b2 gamma 2
okay but you can also further modify the
activity of these receptors by
phosphorylation
and there's various endogenous compounds
there's the neurosteroids
which are just derivatives of steroids
but in this in the general circulation
to arachidon oil glycerol which is an
endocannabinoid that interacts with our
cannabinoid receptors
and interestingly no one has yet found
the natural ligand
for the benzodiazepine binding site
so it may be serendipitous but there may
be another yet another
your modulator waiting to be discovered
right so these isoforms are going to
have different specific specificities
for benzodiazepines and indeed
sophiclone binding
so can we actually therefore directly
compare the effects of any new
benzodiazepine directly to diazepam
which is what i tend to do
i sort of say it's longer that will have
a more powerful effect
but is that is that strictly true we
just don't obviously just don't know
so let's switch tack now to gabapentin
and pregabalin these would actually
develop to be gaba analogue so they were
meant to interact with the gaba receptor
but they're transported across the
blood brain barrier by the system l
transporters which
transports neutral amino acids so like
phaline leucine and isoleucine
and gabapentin and pagabolin actually
bind to vaulted gated
calcium channels and this appears to
reduce neurotransmitter
release gabapentin and gabalin were you
know they were they were touted as being
anti-epileptics and that probably is the
base of this anti-seizure activity
and of course the binding therefore may
be affected by these
amino acids which also bind to this
gated
voltage-gated chelsea calcium channel
so here's the structure and as you can
see gabapentin and the gabalin structure
there
you can see why they gather analogs
but actually what they need is that
hydrophobic area
for the receptor binding and also the
transport via the amino
amino acid transport system
so the interaction between progablin
gabapentin the opioids appeared was
spotted first and this appears to be
more important
but i'm going to take you on to as to
why it might be a portrait of
benzodiazepines
paper came out and plus medicine a few
years ago now
and this was a population based study
from toronto
and they were noting that folk taking
opioids and gabapentin were at a higher
risk of death
compared to those just taking the
opioids but
it could of course be the focal leading
both drugs
are simply just more ill and they've got
more pain and so they'll afford a high
risk of death anyway
but then a further study appeared from
the uk and this was looking at depths
involving
heroin on the like and gabapentin the
this group here the note the
gabapentinoid prescriptions rising by
ridiculous rate
each year okay you know
massive increase in the prescription of
these drugs and the increase in deaths
involving these drugs across parallel
this and the nice
graph that i've just taken from the
paper and as you can see
the that nice lead red line is the gap
of pentamic prescriptions and then
underneath you've got the two
figures showing the increase in depths
and again same data
but produced as a logarithmic scale to
give you a nice straight line
but there's some issues with this
they um quote 137 deaths in 2015.
but we ourselves and indeed quite a few
of the toxicology labs particularly the
nhs ones didn't really look for people
and gather penton
until about 2015.
we found in 2009 to 232 postmortems from
2016 though it's actually 2019 not the
present
2019 at about 1200
cases in total in the uk
statistics regarding drug deaths are
actually quite poor
and it really depends on what corner
states the cause of death so yes
the gathering may well be involved but
the coroner may say well actually the
heroin
in my opinion did it or it was worth
something else
so but again looking back in the
literature with the gablin
the preclinical studies suggested
interaction of the gaba
and the glutamate systems which indicate
there was abuse potential
i also clinical studies of pregabalin
that as it was being introduced
reported euphoria as a common side
effect so it's not really that
surprising that it's been widely abused
in the uk the mhra's are the medicines
and health regulatory agency
they've recently issued a warning that
the government is linked to respiratory
depression
on this linden paper with the data on
the desk they did some work in mice
showing that pregabalin reduces
respiration rate
it's not blocked by naloxone the effect
is still a parenting morphe intolerant
mice it seems to be working by a
different
pathway but more worryingly if you give
morphine and program into more
intolerant mice you get this
significantly reduced respiration
and they're proposing and suggesting
that actually progablin might actually
be
reducing morphine tolerance
and then another study looking at pain
response
um in rodents um i'm sorry as you can
see from this graph
graph morphine and gabapentin together
big response morphine by itself much
lower spots but gabapentin by itself
doesn't really have much
effect on the pain but it really does
amplify the morphine response
the pain so is there a benzodiazepine
interaction
it would seem to make sense there is
the fatalities involving these designer
benzos are actually
usually multi-foot fatalities and i
can't think of one
that hasn't there hasn't been a cocktail
of drugs there
so describing the fatality of one
particular billionaire for actually
impossible you can't say well
the benzodiazepine did all the the
gavilan did it
so is there an interaction between the
benzos and for gaplin strip capital
penta
i think that probably is but i've got no
data to back it up
i'm nothing and at the moment that
doesn't appear to be anything
fondly in the literature but of course
as we all know it takes come time
for data to get from the bench
into the literature could be a year year
and a half depending on the journal
so something else to bear in mind across
the gather penton and indeed the gaplin
is both drugs are cleared by the kidneys
they aren't really metabolized to any
extent at all
a little little while ago we have this
case where
severe renal phalip creatinine in the
vitreous fluid is over 800 micromoles
liters that's severe
renal dysfunction so were the high
levels of gabapentin
because they were high whether due to
poor renal function
but a particular character was found
surrounded by empty medication packets
and they've got increased codeine and
zopiclone but also had a cracking
diabetic ketoacidosis
so you may be picking up this
interaction between
thermopentanoids and sophicle and or
codeine without actually needing
to take the excess levels of drugs you
would see in in
abuse for abuse
so in this final little section i want
to sort of chat through
um some laboratory issues we sort of get
us thinking
about how we should be picking these
drugs up it's sort of confession of that
epidemic
clinical labs often screen for the most
common drugs which are generally those
available by commercial amino acid based
methods for example
cedia or emit
mass spectrometry methods based methods
are actually much better because you can
target the drugs to your local
population what they're actually taking
you also don't have to confirm
any positive immunoassays but
can a local hospital of austria with
limited staffing
limited expense and toxicology actually
run a proper service
so you felt then telling towards a
regional service which got the necessary
skills and expertise
but then it can actually offer tailored
services to all the areas that it serves
so the changes to our screen patterns
which we are
we're working on now have been driven by
the service users so
going out talking to the clinicians
finding out what the clients are saying
to them then targeting the screens to
those drugs that are known to be out
there
talking to public health what are their
concerns
the battle i've got and i've slowed up
win it
winning it thankfully at long last the
nhs national health service in the uk
it can be quite high bound and so it
takes a long time to win the service
management of relying on the amino acids
the easy to do you stick them on a big
main chemistry analyzer you press go and
away you go
google of course let's use our staff
training taking staff out in the main
clinical chemistry lab
rotate shift rotation is problematical
we rely on rotating staff
there are issues there obviously
so we've got ourselves a nice shiny
acute officer take a couple years ago
and i just thought
i would illustrate this by two cases to
show you the difference of what we can
do with a cutoff and actually it's now
become it's made itself indispensable
so this was a few years ago um a person
was admitted to an itu
in the region the initial stasidious
green was positive benzed up for
benzodiazepines
but we couldn't find any trace of
diazepam or metabolites
your positive is flopid combing codeine
the clinicians you know are gone for the
patient's pockets
and they'd finance it produces a tablet
we analyzed it by the tandem we'd
already tuned up
returned them before finazo sometime
prior to this
i think because i probably read in the
literature that it was going to be an
issue in the uk
at the time
the tablet was fantastic and at the time
that was actually quite common in
central scotland
scotland and we're not actually that far
south of scotland
and so things obviously drifted over the
border
but there was no trace of the drug in
the urine
fortunately we got lucky with a paper
the literature and that's the
writing paper i referred to below that
and we were able to use those settings
for the tandem and exactly it worked but
as
those of you use mass spectrometry a lot
will know
it's not necessarily you can use a
tandem settings between different
manufacturers we have different
instruments
the same manufacturer we picked up the
three hydroxy metabolite in the urine
and we subsequently filmed this with a
certified reference material but it was
enough for the clinicians to be able to
say look it's for nasa pam
they will go and we were able to give
them some details of the
pharmacokinetics of the drug
now for our this was
this is post arrival of the qtov okay
we received intelligence from public
health that this drug was being used in
the region
so all we did was imported the mole file
from chemspider and for those of you who
aren't
aware of cam spiders are very useful
resource produced by the world society
chemistry
and you loads of chemicals on that and
you've got a little
ring the around the disk sign click on
that
you get the mole file for that structure
which you can import directly
into the software okay you can also
import them all file into chemsketch or
similar program
and then you can create dot mold files
for possible metabolites you can just
have fun sticking hydroxy groups on
whatever you whatever you think is
reasonable
so we've got a blood sample that's
collected from an
early adopter in the region who refused
to give a
beyond the sample okay
the clinicians have got submissions
about this person um
he may actually he think it's a he
may actually be a dealer anyway
so we simply ran it for the cutoff after
a simple protein crash
okay the analyzer software that's
unified calculated the predicted demo
was out of the molecule
and can also inform in silicon
fragmentation to give
to give you additional you know
certainty you've got it right
we picked up the through alpha zolam in
the blood um
we then fold that up by a tablet that
was helpfully sent to us by public
health
and then identifying them florida sold
them and then
we could then follow it on and say look
we're 95
certain the crms of order will confirm
once we've got that and
we're bang on right we're actually quite
proud of ourselves for that one
we then often set up the confirmatory
method from the tandem so that we've
then got
the screening method using the cutoff
and then we can confirm using the tandem
should there be any doubt
or should that be needed by the powers
that be
so the finaster pam case using the
tandem we simply got
lucky there's no other word for it we
got lucky okay
and that was approximately three days
work and it was
edge of our you know a seat of edge of
our panty to the seat or whatever
in case the law person was actually much
easier result in the patient without the
day
along with a tablet analysis backed up
with a confirmation with the crm
we then were able to get much quicker
warnings out
to public health and the clinicians in
the region and public health were able
to use that
to alert clinicians to what was out
there and what was happening
you don't have to wait for crms to be
available to tune up
your mass spectrometer and you also
don't have to wait
until a helpful paper appears in
literature which of course could be at
least a year after the event
of the of the molecule appearing and so
i'll be doing this
metabolism studies so
that's basically all i have to say so
any questions and
just as you're thinking of your
questions um i'd like to thank the staff
from the lab
particularly ann who's my amazing deputy
who is less than developing work with a
cutoff into a useful clinical service
and as well
of the work on the post-mortem service
i'd also like to thank public health in
the region particularly
side for all the information they send
us and what's made us successful
and made us useful to people is the fact
that we operate as a multi-disciplinary
service with corporation which i part of
my job really is why i don't
can't tell you much about the lab
analysis is i spend the bulk of my life
writing reports or talking to people
to find out what they want explain our
findings
and it's actually very important greatly
appreciated
so thank you very much and as again any
questions